the motion feels very CG but like the
look is very hand-painted it's really
cool to see how far they're pushing the
poses and not forgetting depth
I love the shot of her just kicking and
it just like shakes her gun oh yeah yeah
I really got to see the show like
watching all of this I'm just like oh
it's so good
huge thanks to keeps for sponsoring
today's episode Stick Around to the end
to get 50 off the best products to keep
the hair that you have hey welcome back
to another episode of animators react to
the first one of the year we've got Alex
snow on the couch for the first time no
longer those fold up chairs welcome back
man good to be here yeah I'm excited
it's way more comfy so Alex just to
brief anyone who may not know who you
are tell us a little bit about yourself
uh I'm an animator I'm working at Disney
just finished on a contos Utopia plus
and now I'm on Strange World the next
film coming out in November been busy
it's a strange world
you can't just say the words back you
can't just say the words back you can
say whatever you want you have to put a
little twist on them yep so there's a
show on Netflix called Arcane this is
one of the most heavily requested things
for us to look at and why should we
watch this oh a million reasons it's
doing a lot that's never happened before
the quality is at another level the
style is a whole new thing also a huge
difference is it's a series it's
essentially like four movies
the motion feels very CG but like the
look is very hand-painted it's just yeah
it's a really cool blend while you're
feeling like it's hand painted and it's
somewhere between 2D and 3D is it is
both through texturing and also the 2D
effects you're seeing there all the
major effects are 2D there's some CG
effects from what I understand there's
about five people on the team I I know
some of them and they're all amazing for
the effects okay so there's five 2D
animators from what I understand as at
least the main team for all the 2D
effects across the whole series when you
say the 2D effects you're specifically
referring to like a little like Explorer
yeah like look at her gloves kind of
yeah a little smoke coming out yeah the
smoke coming out that's all 2D
composited onto the CG so it says
hand-drawn elements completely
hand-drawn I would say 98 of the effects
are hand-drawn so all these green trails
and little bits and shock waves all that
is 2D the CG animators did like put
something in there for some scenes to
give a guide to the 2D and also there
are 2D effects kind of figured out and
plan for in the storyboard phase but
their storyboards are really specific
and signed off on and they're really
going off that it doesn't move much
the budget was a lot but it's not even
close to what it costs to make like a
Disney movie or a DreamWorks movie it's
doing that by spending all its money on
two teams this doesn't work in the
current pipeline of most Studios what's
interesting from what I understand from
their team is those painters are
basically responsible for everything so
whether it's the everything yeah the
textures on the characters the textures
on the backgrounds a lot of those
backgrounds are not CG at all they're
just composite or flat so the
backgrounds are effectively painted back
on this for a lot of traditional
animation style you painted a picture
and that's it to an extent yeah but then
it's taking it to that next level of
like multi-plane where like you'll see
Riot trailers where it's just like a
character with a cape flowing or
whatever it's like an ad for the card
game or whatever and they're warping the
2D in a way that the camera moves just a
little bit and then they're also
modeling based off the painting and
projecting that on as well the
projection mapping aspect of this this
is really cool because you can have the
high quality artwork but then also
combine that with a moving digital
camera that geometry now exists in 3D
space like we're talking about and then
you can move that digital camera so then
you get like that sort of perspective
shift on a 2D image making it look
three-dimensional there's also still the
ability to light on top of those
projected textures say you do this couch
right you might not get all these little
bumps and crevices but it will warp
around this so you'll see a mixture of
all three where a corner of a room with
molding on the bottom the shadow is just
flat against the molding but it does
warp around the corner of the room
because they're projecting the textures
that make it feel like the molding is
there it's almost like an old video game
exactly where it's like you're faking
the detail because it's in the
background yeah it's like there's no
displacement map right
the interesting thing about Arcane and
from what I can understand is there's
very little actual lighting being done
on this show really so there's not
really a lighting department from what I
heard so all of the lighting is coming
from the actual painting or a decent
amount of it because I am seeing some
specular highlight detail on their
shoulder pads and whatnot as they're
moving and catching those light
highlights this is why this is done so
well it's really hard to pinpoint when
certain things are being used because I
think they're using all of them so
Disney or DreamWorks or Pixar you're
having the eyes light different than the
face so that they are never too dark
because that's what you're connecting to
even this is like a intense lighting
setup you guys got here and this is
nothing compared to CG where you have to
pretend that it's natural light but also
get everything exactly the way you want
it and that's the beauty of Animation
Beyond making a cartoony making it this
and that you get it to be exactly what
you want so when you have CG animation
you know the computer is basically
automatically doing a lot of the
lighting the shading you know all that
kind of stuff for you right yeah you
just you kind of Define things I have a
light here and I want to cast this kind
of Shadows to be this color yeah it's
like okay so the surface of the
character will be like this the shadow
will be here whereas here you're
bringing back the artist so the artist
is going I want to put a shadow here and
I want to put a highlight here so I'm
going to take my literally my paintbrush
digital paintbrush and go
and like put the colors down the colors
I want at the values I want and there's
still some CG happening where the
computer is also going I'm also going to
add some lighting here just to save you
some time and I'll do a little
perspective shift here to save the time
I'm having to redraw that but you're
kind of blending the two worlds together
which brings back almost like the
slightly surreal not quite yeah
realistic version of light that we all
find so endearing when we look at
paintings and hand-drawn animations
there's a saying in art color doesn't
matter as much it's all about the light
values if you can make a painting or
some sort of photo or image work using
nothing but just black and white values
you can throw any color in there and
it's not going to matter because the
thing that matters most are those light
values but they're working really
economical I mean there's another fight
scene where Vai fights the cyborg arm
Soldier
the arm of the cyborg character it has
like two flaps here that go like this
and then the shoulder pad sometimes does
that and then other than that the arm
stretches that's it that's the only
thing in the rig I think people when
they're like oh I gotta model this crazy
mechanical thing it's a robot arm I want
it interesting like Megatron and
transforming and then you look at this
and you watch it and it feels like that
I just see that little bicep thing twist
a little bit but again that like
enforces what you're saying though it's
very simple instead of having a whole
bunch of stuff going around it's like
the cylinder just goes yeah you'll see a
shot here where she grabs her arm and
punches Up Normally like you'd see that
her hand shouldn't be in frame right
they're bringing the hand in and
cranking that arm back so that you can
see the hand for just two frames and the
spacing is really close so you catch it
coming into frame and then you're able
to do this big smear frame also if you
put a marker like where that fist is the
elbow is not at the same point either
because that'll give it like a like a
sticky feel the animator is making sure
you see it it's the antic and then
popping up so with an antic what I mean
by that is anticipation so that's a big
thing in animation for storytelling and
for natural motion natural motion
generally you antic everything and the
antic is relative to the expectation so
if I move here here here you know where
I'm going right if I'm about to slap
Nico and I'm doing it for real uh no you
know I wouldn't want to be the
Storyteller we're both sitting here and
then all of a sudden unless you want it
to be like the Hulk shot and even that
it has a little bit of an antic right
before if the storytelling was slapping
Nico and it was like really big the
faster I want that slap to be probably
the bigger antic like Looney Tunes like
the more here I go the more you can just
zip off yeah like you can literally
and then literally just like turn the
layer off Neo taking off the Matrix
boom and one frame is gone 100 but if he
just was like hey everyone
oh wait what happened as an audience
it's not telling the story of course
physics and things like that and you're
pretending that he can do that yeah so
the bigger anticipation also the more
believable it is because you're going oh
you need a lot of force the antic is
also a storytelling moment so it's
saying here I come and then oh it's easy
to follow and you can push the expected
return based on that anticipation
there's a video it's live action I just
thought this was super funny how
important it is
the money
tell me oh wow
this is like basically what magicians do
yeah
I mean this guy's good
Ness
that's great no this is exactly what
you're talking about because he has all
of the anticipation for moves that we
already know and expect but then he
doesn't deliver on it exactly like you
don't realize that you're anticipating
literally everything all the time so if
I'm going like this and then I walk the
other way it's also like can be a
disappointment
foreign
[Music]
comments leave a comment down below if
you got them do you want maybe those
comments to be like suggestions as the
things we should look at no absolutely
not today's comment I want you to just
say nice
Imagine Dragons okay yeah that means
yeah this is definitely not gonna be on
YouTube so subscribe to Corridor
digital.com to check this section of the
video out
foreign
my favorite clips
in the story The Boxing thing is
something her sister does and so this is
her older and she's kind of revisiting
this and she's kind of doing it in her
own very different than her sister way
but it's really cool because it's so
many things going on but it's easy to
follow so it's keeping the movement
really smooth the pose is really clear
I love the shot of her just kicking and
it just like shakes her gun oh yeah yeah
you really just read that one pose but
because of the jiggle it sells as motion
yeah it gives the energy it's really
cool to see how far they're pushing the
poses and not forgetting depth I think a
lot of animators kind of work on this
puppet stage where you know we're kind
of on right now I'm not moving in a 2d
space like this you know there's depth
I'm leaning forward I'm coming back
depth is so important to Performance and
I think it's something Junior animators
forget a lot about because they're so
focused on what's moving where and the
arcs and the principles that they forget
they're working in 3D space I tend to
really focus on that 3D space when I'm
starting to kind of block or start my
shot that way I can then Focus through
the camera on my poses and get the
drawings to be what I want them to be
and you can see like hair in this show
is such a part of the flow and it's no
different than an arms part of what's
adding energy and posing and flow to the
animation and so it's super important
that the animator kind of handle that or
at least create kind of like the base
for that and then you can always build
on top yeah if you're gonna try to like
simulate those braids she'd do the kick
and be like
like flip over and like hit her front
and then like just kind of like dangle
there as she continues the motion maybe
gets stuck around her neck or something
so it's like no there has to be
intention behind the motion there and so
that has to be manually animated so that
actually reminds me I've been playing
this game called Horizon forbidden West
love the game but the main character has
like this hair that is really long and
it's physically simulated so every time
she likes moves or sits down it's like
her hair is chaotic all over the place
yeah yeah I mean that's definitely the
downside to leaning too heavily on
Dynamics and the other side is it feels
too stiff for not having every fine hair
move together it feels like big chunks
which is not how long hair necessarily
works when it sits on your shoulder it
will get fatter it will have some wash
to it and some separation it's almost
like a lion paw stepping the pressure of
that line plus separates your finger
dang you're right one nuanced
observation about how hair moves yeah I
mean everything has the same elements I
think it's just how much can you
actually dive in your shot with your
limited time and build that on top of a
performance that's already believable or
flows in a way that sells the shot I
mean at the end of the day all that
matters is a storytelling and you know
if two guys shake hands this is all that
matters is that does it in a cool way or
you know arcs in squats stretch and
smears yeah explosions a big
anticipation yeah so you have to
integrate all these principles into it
to build a believability and the style
but at the end of the day that's all
that matters I really got to see this
show like I already knew I wanted to see
it but like watching all of this I'm
just like oh so good hey guys this is
the part where I asked you to subscribe
but guess what bookmark this page
that's right make this video your home
page uh your default load up page if you
haven't made this thumbnail your phone
lock screen at this point then you've
failed us but if you don't want to do
that hit subscribe help these guys out
and catch us next time so you don't miss
some awesome episodes
hey hi it's me can you see hey can you
see me I'm way down here yeah yeah hi
tiny tiny in the image right now but
guess what you know what isn't tiny
today's sponsor keeps keeps is a
subscription service that focuses on
making it easier and more affordable for
men to treat male pattern baldness
online and you might be thinking Jake
that's great but where the heck is the
show and why are you telling me about
this why are you standing in this huge
field well the answers to all of those
questions I can tell you in a minute but
here let me give you a fact okay did you
know that two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 I mean
hip hip hooray because what do you do to
keep the hair that you still have well
you got to treat it and the best way to
treat it is to use keeps they give you
online doctor consultations where you
can talk to a doctor get a consultation
and a recommendation from them directly
about the type of medication that you
need and then that medication ships
directly to your door every three months
which allows you to take more time to do
the things that you love and enjoy and
not spend time going to the doctor's
office to get treated for male pattern
baldness super great oh and another way
that they help you do this is they give
you 24 7 access to your doctor through a
great online doctor messaging system
which also allows you to track your
progress you hit them up you get the
information that you need you move on
with your life it's it's actually pretty
genius and the last thing that keeps
does is they give you generic versions
of FDA approved medications which not
only allows you to keep the hair that
you have but also allows you to keep
money because you're not spending
unnecessary amounts of money on name
brand drugs no you're getting the exact
same drug just the generic version isn't
that nice gosh these guys are so nice if
you are experiencing some form of male
pattern baldness and you want to treat
it keeps is a great way to do it they've
got hundreds of thousands of men who
already trusted they've got a bunch of
great reviews online and they can give
you 50 off your first order if you want
to get started that's 50 off by going to
keeps.com
Corridor crew or just click the link in
the description below keeps.com slash
Corridor crew so there you have it thank
me later or now whatever you want and
hey now let's get back to the episode
what are those guys reacting to anyway
it's definitely not a field
Alex thank you so much for coming on the
show today this was a huge blast to
shoot with you I can't wait to have you
on the show again next time absolutely
it's always fun coming and I would
absolutely love to come back and talk
about more animation 2D 3D I really want
to make sure we're looking at stuff you
guys are interested in you guys should
check out Alex's Instagram snowmation
and his company's Instagram double plus
Productions if you want to see what he
is actively working on right now or even
if you want to send him a question
that's right I'm inviting you to get DMS
for everybody no they're welcome I'm
always happy to hear questions or help
any way I can anyone out there thank you
so much for watching we'll see you back
here tomorrow tomorrow or you know next
hit the next button thanks